your um thank you come on in how's it
going good good we're on the air just so
you know okay yes normally we don't like
to tell people that we're hoping they
say something stupid and inflammatory do
we want to have a good yeah yeah yeah we
saw you at Fox we didn't hear what you
said we just got that we got to watch
you a little contributed for those guys
oh yes okay what made the decision I
guess to start because you know usually
it's so secretive and nobody knows who
did what
what made you the decision for you to
actually come out and talk and let
everybody know and by the way Rob is
plugging his book the operator firing
the shots that killed Osama bin Laden
and my years as a SEAL team warrior well
that was a unique time because when from
the time that we the team killed bin
Laden to the time we flew back the word
had already started to spread it was
like what's the first question you asked
like who did it and so guys in the SEAL
community and their friends around town
sort of nua so it kind of came out
slowly like that and it was kind of an
uncomfortable time because the team did
it the agency found him we were just the
the end of it you know we were guys they
told last we went in and did and then I
made a donation to the memorial up here
and then after talking to Jarrett Wright
other short yes talking to a lot of the
survivors that had had family members
died in the towers and having them say
that they'll you know they'll never be
closure but this helps with the healing
that we know it's a real name a real
face this is uh this happened that kind
of pushed me towards the I got it I got
to tell them if I can help a few people
here and in this auditorium I can I can
probably help thousands of them it's
it's a that's one reason then it's just
the whole story I mean it's if the book
is called the operator because it's the
life of the operators now I'm not
calling myself saying on myself out a
lot of guys go through this operators or
Ranger SEALs Green Berets all that stuff
Marines and this is the lot of the story
about starting as a normal person just
going to feel like it's chapter 23 is
the bin Laden raid it's not about the
right the proof is if you stay positive
and never quit doesn't matter where
you're from what you look like you can
do anything you want I mean I joined the
Navy because of a girl because of a
breakup and drunk right it's pretty much
and then I did it you know it turned
into well I found out what seals are and
I it'll be just be cool to try the
training and other four years I'll come
back with some awesome stories from
friends of Butte Montana and then I met
the guys the other operators I'm like
well god I can't leave these guys I got
it I got to stick around with them so I
reenlist it and then 9/11 happened like
well I'm not leaving now they trained me
to fight for you know eight years I got
to go fight and then I found out about
other SEAL Teams I went there and then
you know I'm with a group of guys that
on a large coalition team that rescued
the lone survivor I found myself on my
birthday 2009 leaving my daughter's
classroom preschool classroom and 16
hours later we're in the Indian Ocean to
rescue Richard Phillips same guys did we
got called in for the bin Laden raid we
flew around the base when that dude Bowe
Bergdahl walked off you know this is all
wow we're it's like it's almost like in
Iraq right he's the guy that didn't he
just kind of go into office a metallic
grab them and he was a prisoner for five
years I mean just going through he'll
catch up if I want to ask you a question
to first what the Pakistani government
did I did they knew bin Laden was there
and we had no idea even though he's
right by the West Point on by for a sec
I was asking certain parts of the
government they've got their own
interests they have interests with
allies so some know some don't the
military maybe didn't but their
intelligence service did they have
interest in hiding him because maybe if
we protect them they al-qaeda won't
attack us to speak there were some
people didn't know he didn't I don't
think he lived right there and nobody
knew there's there's a there's a
high-ranking Pakistani intelligence
officer living less than a couple
hundred yards away from him today know
they had it know something was and we
had we had Trump on the phone one time
before he's president before he ran for
president and I asked him on the phone
like I gave Obama credit for authorizing
I thought it was a ballsy thing you're
going use it was definitely both but
becomes like no any president would have
done that and I'm like I don't know they
didn't know a hundred percent he
authorized them to go into Pakistan
which was a flaw I mean they gave him a
few options and it was a you know the
missile thing a joint effort with the
Pakistani mi5 options and he decided on
it was usually he did a great job and he
did authorizes his call and he just said
I wasn't a hundred percent sure that bin
Laden was there but I was 100% sure that
you guys could go and find out and come
back which he had more confidence in US
living than I did like I thought we were
going in one way like that's it when you
thought you were dense yeah we're gonna
it was almost to the point where looking
up at the building it's like I'm gonna
die tonight but this is historic and I'm
going to I'm going to treasure this I'm
going to this is cool and then
you know I'm watching really cool guys
other operators to really cool stuff
that I described that in the book what
they're doing what I started thinking
that these guys are cool go up the
stairs while the analysts told us we'd
run into bin Laden's son which we did
amazing story of how the appointment
took him down and then we go up the
stairs I turn right after watching you
know one of my best friends jump on what
he thought were suicide bombers so the
guy behind him get the shot I'd say
there's been lon three feet away so the
tactics got me there so so mentally is
the secret to doing this because I've
seen like other interviews you down you
talk about how like you know part of
being a CEO is also it's just not
allowing time to become your enemy just
because you have so much of it like you
would sit there and just count down and
count down is is part of it to just be
in the moment at all times like you said
knives accounting was - yeah to get your
mind off of it I'd done it before I
learned as a sniper I'd worked also in
Kosovo right around 9/11 we're doing
recon and surveillance and just sitting
there staring at a group of houses you
need to occupy your mind you lose it so
I just arted counting and then on the
flight in de mons house I started
counting again and just because we can
get blown up at any time no one knows
what these helicopters work we're
invading a nation they can shoot us down
and we can't even be mad at them because
we're invading right like of course
that's very I'm not a Maddie but then
you know you start counting and then it
was it was one of those things it's
almost Hollywood as we turned we banked
80 minutes into a 90 minute flight and I
was counting something like 556 557 and
in my mind I said freedom itself was
attacked this morning by a faceless
coward and freedom will be defended and
that's what President Bush that on 9/11
he dressed the world and I'm like whoa
I'm on this mission this is it so it did
hit you it hit me then and then it's
sort of sunk in when I when I shot him
and I had another guy come in and in the
room after me and he said he looked at
me said are you okay and I said yeah
what do we what do we do now and he said
we find the computers bro we've done
this hundreds of times yeah you're right
my god you just killed a lot in like
your life changed yeah and you knew in
the moment like this is that was it I
don't yeah this is this is big this is a
big one was there resentment from the
other guy I like because again they say
team effort
but it's not a team effort no no that it
is but do they start to feel like
he adamantly didn't stuff when I
explained it in the book to that like
when the lead sniper for the Phillips
raid the souls rescue took the initial
shot some guys were so close to him but
didn't get a shot they're mad at him and
it's just a it's an alpha male thing a
lot I mean you know did any any ceil in
my position would have done what I did I
sure and get there but if you're that
closest I mean it's yeah you some people
five grips and that's fine and
especially if guys were on the mission I
respect anything they say is fine if
you're mad about it and mad about it but
it's a it's a historic story there's
nothing wrong with being proud of a
great American thing that we did minute
that's what it was it's a great story do
you think that they don't like the fact
that you're speaking about it because a
lot of them at home it like who God and
they're like I can't say that a lot and
generally it's like if the guy that says
well I can't talk about it's like well
you probably have anything to talk about
right because I mean I you know I know a
lot of seals I know a lot of pilots I
know a lot of Marines and if they've
done some they'll tell you they'll tell
you about it I mean some guys are
quieter than others but you know the
guys that obviously I can't talk about
it but that's they're usually not not
much there
do you have times in daily life because
you said in the book you talk about
being on the way to you got on the way
to take off for this mission you're in
still in the SEPA generator or Miami and
you look driving by people and you're
going no they have no idea what these
bearded guys are about to go and do yeah
it was it was a it was a pretty surreal
feeling I mean just from the moment that
the commanding officer from that SEAL
team came in and said the reason you
guys are here is because this is as
close as we've ever been to Osama bin
Laden's it was cool looking around at my
these are my brothers and just seeing
that there was no cheering there was it
was just like bye we going now just
about a bunch of pros and they're ready
to rock and roll and we're ready that
day but we had to train for a few weeks
just something at that level you need to
convince people that are actually making
the calls hey we can do this we'll do it
just fine in the helicopters well
ideally won't fall out of the sky and
and which one did yeah yeah that was a
funny story too because a life is what
happens around you while you're planning
for us and that was like on a Wednesday
week and a half into planning it we had
the perfect plan
and one of the bosses he's all tired
he's like alright what's the worst thing
that could happen I think it was the
youngest guy in the room said the
helicopter could crash in the front yard
maybe which is like don't talk about
that for 30 seconds
and that's what happened the worst thing
yeah but you guys and then you try to
blow off I mean which I know were
jumping all over I don't care Stefan
Sorenson yeah you went to blow off the
the front gate yeah we knew there was a
gate on the northeast side so we went to
blow that and we it was I mean it's
what's neat about this to this book a
lot of people that go through this
training great senses of humor because
you need to if you can't laugh at some
point you'll lose your mind so we joked
about we're going to get to this place
and it's going to be one of those
hallways that give small and small and
it's like open line you know like a bug
we went to the northeast corner where we
knew there was a gate we put a charge on
him blew it and it opened like a tin can
into a brick wall it was a fake door
it's like this has happened then but and
the even the breacher was like this is
bad and I'm like no this is good that's
a fake door he's in here they wouldn't
do that because they're right because we
wouldn't there wouldn't be that kind of
security and then we didn't nobody right
I know the helicopter crashed it's
always we announced that we don't know
where it was like we're going to blow
the front door and they said well we'll
just open it so like what and then the
door opens the thumb came out like a
thumbs up and that's the point where
like you know what I worrying about why
they're in there now doesn't matter
we'll talk about it after I don't care
how they got in there other guys are in
there and didn't know the helicopter
crew it's amazing bin Laden must have
been in this house like oh like some
american becoming his worst night the
only good like you look at like he had
at least a 30 minute nightmare however
long it took you guys to get up there 15
minutes i think it was the guys were so
good and we're so good at we've been it
in combat so like this was like mission
419 for me personally other guys had
done more and it's a it's uh there's
were so quiet so going up the stairs
there's really good stories in there
about i don't they might not have known
what was going on they heard of crash
i'm assuming and we were creeping up the
stairs of the dark were quiet and
they could have thought that you guys
had come and that your helicopter had
crashed and you would you'd fail they
couldn't hear no he heard the helicopter
crash he heard shots and then he heard
another one is like well there's khalid
and his wife might like anything's
happening it's an ugly story cuz it's in
the book and always self-doubt in the
book that I saw the point men deal with
Khalid and I remember thinking I really
hope we lived through this because
that's the coolest thing I've ever seen
I never would have thought it it was
really great and just the way you
describe and again you have
to read the book as I read it and it was
like I saw zero dark thirty I saw but
there's still things in the book from
your point of view that I didn't know
yeah and there was a lot of money you
just find out that the the most simple
answer is what happened that's what we
did and it wasn't I mean there are parts
in there where we're fighting these
tough online jihadis and seriously
asking each other after a big fight like
are we missing the war because that's
easy right but are these the toughs guy
okay I mean we're just here and but when
me turns out we're fighting the guys
that are Isis now but it wasn't it was
the problem for just an amazing team
what do you think was the bet like when
you look at him and he stayed hidden for
ten years
I mean his his team I guess the courier
was a very effective guy and didn't turn
the phone on till he was 90 minutes away
that's right I've been a very smart but
what do you think finally did them in
like I was obviously that woman caught
yeah I think it was just her
determination there was a you mentioned
the movie zero dark thirty it was about
a woman it was it was actually a team of
women that found him but there was one
woman in particular that was the one
that think he's a hundred percent just
why are we waiting
go get him he's there and she wanted to
bomb him she didn't really want us to go
but she turned out to be pretty happy
there's a good story in her in there too
about she was pacing outside and was
like why you nervous he's like are you
kidding me why aren't you nervous I'm
like well we do this every night I mean
this is we fly somewhere missing people
up fly back this is a longer fly you
need to be right so hi I'm amazing I
guess I was gonna say at what point do
you realize that you might be going home
because like you said you go in a
meeting it was wrong we know we were
flying out we were leaving on a
helicopter different helicopter because
we had more operators coming to get us
so we had other guys in there that were
in a different one and we're flying out
and now it's like okay we got 90 minutes
like we might live through tonight and
if we get 90 minutes we have 50 years of
life like this this could be good for
everybody and then you're looking at
your watch like say okay spent 10 spent
20 spent 30 minutes we're flying 40
minutes night you know you're thinking
it and the way I described it as using a
sports analogy it's like watching a
no-hitter at Yankee Stadium right top of
the 6th I don't want the same thing I'll
just say so but this is this is what's
amazing though that other people take
into account that like you can't let's
not get all excited and think that we're
going to live live for another hour like
let's not put the Hort let it it was
just so funny for like looking around
near 70 minutes and now if you can and
another sports analogy it's like up and
Lake Placid to the hockey game when the
Americans beat the Russians people are
counting down but they don't want to
count too loud like Ryan 9 you and then
over the radio the pilot says I
gentlemen for the first time in your
lives you're going to be happy to hear
this welcome to Afghanistan really we
did it you knew you were in and you knew
you were out you may say it makes F
ganna stand we live a minute touching us
have you talked about before which is
the idea of going to kill this guy and
you guys know the mission do you and I'm
sure people some people recognize you
and some people don't now that you've
been on TV do you ever have an
interaction in daily life whether it's
like you're online at the airport of
doing something someone's just kind of
being a dick and you're like God you
have no idea it's gotta be tempted I
think the best one I had is it was a I
came out with a special on Fox a couple
years ago and I wasn't used to anyone
recognizing me I wasn't used anyone
especially knowing my name and I was
behind a woman and heard her high school
age daughter at LaGuardia and I heard
her say thank you for what you did and I
looked up and she's kind of staring at
me and she elbowed her daughter and said
this is Rob O'Neil and the daughter
looked at me she goes oh man we have a
test about you on Monday and I was like
what do you mean it's a current events
course in high school I said well ok do
you have a pen and paper and she said
yeah so I said what's your name and she
said it's Victoria so I said Victor I
said put please give Victoria an A and
then I we took a selfie and I'm like
she's like what do I do with this I said
you show your teacher and you say you
took her assignments so serious that you
found me
you know just like a little thing like
that or what you should have done was
give it a really wrong information just
as she failed the test
it's not even close to what happened
yeah no not at all I was in Iran what
it's all one day no less years ago but
even being like a contributor to Fox
News Thank You Lloyd for me you know I
get having that as a career but I feel
like if I'd gone through what you went
through and somebody was like oh would
you hear about this news story like what
do you think I'd be like do you what I
shot bin Laden why would we talk about
anything else well I think there's so
much more to it because you know we were
we were at that I hate the term tip of
the spear but we were you know a tier
one unit and the guys in there aren't
just these you know their stories are
these murderous whatever these are smart
dudes that analyze stuff they come up
with the plans and so I'm just just some
of the stuff with some of my [ __ ]
I still in the Navy still in the the
Marine Corps is like I'm able to get on
they're sort of I try to dumb it down
it's like this is what's happening I
don't need to get on television tell you
a lot of names of this and that's what I
sound smart it's like bad guys are here
good guys are here we probably should
try this just I mean I don't you know
trying to get the political just try to
tell the truth as best I can so do you
feel like because I kind of feel like
when when things happen more and more
nowadays that for some reason society
here in America has gotten less tolerant
of killing bad guys whereas like right
around 9/11 and right around when you
doing to have people were or hungry for
justice and and well the problem is with
everything being so fast patient or
mobile devices the people the problem
with never forgetting is people forget
to never forget so they all of a sudden
time heals everything you forget about
stuff and then with with everything
being on social media you see how
violent it is and war is violent and
killing people is very very violence
very fast like I just talked about in
the book about seeing a suicide bomber
it's just he's there he explodes it's
like alright I'm good that was fast it's
a permanent nasty nasty thing and you
know justice does need to be served a
lot of people don't they don't need to
see what it looks like it's not pretty
and that's what do you think skews
people's opinions is that some of these
people are not trained to even see what
it actually looks like and I mean it is
surprising because a lot of violent
stuff out there when we were always just
as humane as we could be you know we had
a lot of latitude as far as rules of
engagement at first then it started to
change and we're you know we're not
saying we can prove they're women and
children in that cave that are shooting
at you but we're not saying we can't say
that they're not kind of stuff but right
we were never you know we were always
very precise what we did always hit when
you aim at I was fortunate never see a
child get hurt it was a precision but
the really was solid solid dudes when
you would you walk here sergeant when
you walk into bin Laden's bedroom and
you see that it's him what's that mean
obviously you're not thinking in react
it was about a less than a second of
target identification I saw him I
remember I mean I can see it if I close
my eyes taller than I thought skinnier
than I thought beard is gray shorter
than I thought that just knows he's a
threat he's not surrendering you needed
to put him down
that's because he's a suicide bomber I
would have died was going in the going
up the stairs even it wasn't a bravery
thing it's like I'm tired
thinking about this let's get in there
and he's gonna blow up he didn't and
then that's it
what is house smell like or they have no
smell to know it smelled like it was it
was similar inside to a lot of the
houses so it smelled like an Afghan a
house in Afghanistan especially we we
blown a few charges so smells is that
the distinct air of gunshots were fired
so smoky almost but you know was a as
far as complexity it wasn't it was the
most difficult house we've seen it
wasn't it's not even the best story in
the book I mean there's other stuff that
we did in there just watching what
happens that's not love guys figuring
out the hard way that there are belt
doorbells on houses in Iraq leaning up
against all of a sudden the doorbell
rings and watching the breaches putting
a bomb on like I guess we don't have
that roll this back up we'll say that
for the target in the door because it's
a terrorist are looking for you just
Cheryl we're humans like that was easy
yeah and we look at the boss like we
should just do that every night I think
he feels opening to do and there's the
Americans accommodate other stuff in
there too by going to Afghanistan I
remember talking to some of my friends
that went before I did and I was like
how was it over there and they said you
just need to see it you're you you think
I'm lying you'd like people believe in
fire-breathing dragons like they don't
know how old they are then all the time
is just go see it and it's true I mean a
lot of those places the valleys it's a
completely different world I'm from
Montana I've never seen mountains like I
did in Afghanistan just steep and rocky
and it's an incredible adventure all
because I got I got dumped and what was
what was something when you're training
to be a seal like what what what was the
thing for you was maybe not the most
difficult but the most annoying like I
can't do this the the swims I we would
do we swam all the time of seals and
there was always a time to ocean swim
and I when I joined the Navy I didn't
really know how to swim and I go to SEAL
training those guys that played like
college to water polo and stuff and
really good swimmers and so that I was
worried I knew I wasn't going to quit
just because that would have made so
many people right because you know you
joined the Navy to be a seal from Butte
Montana no one's going to know there's
no way no one makes it through this but
the sweat I knew I wouldn't quit but I
knew that I might not pass these swims
but I never failed to swim so and what
were the
we're how long were you swimming for two
miles two nautical miles Wow so it's
like from the training compound of San
Diego up to the hotel bill and then back
down and it's so weird to be to look at
the people on the beach one of the most
beautiful beaches in the world of
Coronado and you're out there getting
tortured they're not even famous I'm
gonna stop this because I have a couple
of myths I want to ask you these made up
if you love it ah the first one when you
win Obama comes in and you guys talk to
President Obama I did he asked who
actually got him just his normal
question and nobody would tell him it
was uh he didn't ask me I had one of his
I one of his I forgot who did it but
they did ask myself in another seal and
we just said we all did it it was we all
did and then when he walked away my
buddy said you could have just old one
it was you like well did you want to
tell me no no it was a human right if
they were well we all did it and then
you saw much more than others if you
stood out just inbound with a guy who
did nothing you know you're in a room
full of great operators and you don't
want the attention it's not it's not
because the team did right said I'm well
I got up to the third floor because of
the guys over in front of me they
breached the door they climbed the
stairs they got rid of Khalid bin Laden
and then it just my turn to go up into a
room tactics got me there did you guys
take I heard that you must have taken a
souvenir of some sort no we know you're
here no nothing um it was it was such a
big time that personally I'll I was
thinking about was let's find the stuff
that we'll be able to prosecute more
targets what al-qaeda is up to where the
rest of us find is we have a time limit
and then let's live let's see if we can
live I wasn't concerned I mean looking
back on it's like you know anything yeah
might even cooler but knob at the time
it was grab what you can God anything
electronic any thumb drive any disks and
he take a hard drive out of out of a
tower of a computer and get it back turn
everything over and we turned everything
over as far as I know to the to the the
agency people that were there and we
just wanted to it was such a big thing
you know and the photos there was any
guys took a lot of photos you said but
it was like dummy photos going around
that warrant the Andals I'm sure I've
seen him on the internet why haven't
they really or what do you thinking I
think they haven't because the initial
the initial reason was because they
didn't want up up rising I mean people
get murdered over cartoons what are they
going to do about this
um if it gets too I mean I don't it
happened been lots dead we killed them
but if I don't know if they want to
release and they can they're I mean
they're more graphic than the fake ones
I I assume that they were and I know
that they burned him at sea so there's
no site for martyrdom this was kind of
made sense yeah where do you think when
they where's al Zawahiri he's like the
number two guy diseased up in Pakistan
somewhere he's yeah he's up in those in
one of the tribal areas I would guess
you know he's kind of quiet
he's not as charismatic he's he's
obviously the number one al Qaeda guy
but I wasn't he's like the real result
in the group like like bin Laden yeah
money he was yeah he was definitely a
crazy more it's hard to say more
fanatical but he was the guy that
screams in the prisoners yelling that
all this stuff and bin Laden was more
the charismatic mastermind except to the
point where people weren't sure if he
was running it but he was from that
house that we found when you talk about
I mean how graphic the photos were I
don't know if people realized that you
guys had to push he's a headbanger the
other pictures yeah yeah a lot of if
anyone criticizes anything about that
they've never seen what someone who did
you got shot in the face looks like
right it's I mean and it's like sorry we
didn't kill them nice enough but but
that today I know right maybe people who
said you don't want to shoot them in
this it's like well you've never dealt
with a suicide bomber there's one way to
see don't shoot them in the chest people
people take a lot longer to die than you
would think really a suicide bomber
shoot him in the head Sonny Corleone it
took 30 shots to kill you had to do it
right to the face how good did it feel
is that what the first shot went right
into the temple yeah I hit up three
times in the head
three hours rest it was as fast and we
done it before we we train to a point at
that SEAL team to take head shots
because our primary mission is hostage
rescue and if you're rescuing a hostage
you need to eliminate the threat if you
negotiate fail which we've done so we
get we take you always say the double
tap to the chest one of the head now
sits two or three to the head so they
don't really think with the police they
say you shoot for mass that's why the
people so shoot for the legs they can't
they shoot for like a center mass that
means here but it's you got a lot of
stuff going on when you're talking about
shooting people people were moving
people don't want to get shot it takes I
mean I I must have fired my weapon a
couple million times before I went to
war just training to do it there's a lot
to it and anyone can Monday Morning
Quarterback my shoot him in the leg why
didn't you shoot the gun out of his hand
why do you work in a cubicle you know I
think I think that was the best purchase
record for target one time when uh an
awkward question is always how many
kills you have someone asked my buddies
how many kills you have he goes I don't
know how many emails you type today you
know no did you have a friend to this
this has got to just suck one of the
guys on the team he had no idea they had
announced a mission was and he asked to
be taken off it because he was preparing
for something there was there were a few
guys that did that one guy needed
shoulder surgery
one guy was running a trip in January
and he wanted to go out there to plan it
it's a lot going on and no one knew what
they were doing and they willingly took
themselves off the big mission I know
guys that went to training to be
instructors to date if they would have
waited two days they would have been on
the mission but they went to assist with
training so just yeah it just it was
great time
it was so did you know how mad you must
be when you get pulled off probably what
is considered the most important seal
mission which is telling the number one
terrorist in the world just being a part
of it was an honor it was trying a magic
and pole I know how I would fly would be
really bitter well you guys were also
scheduled you your team was supposed to
be on the perimeter for you weren't even
supposed to be in the house I was the
team leader for the snipers on the
outside and when the female analyst was
so convincing that the rooftop team is
probably going to get them I just like
we're going to need more people so I'm
going to have team leaders out there let
the other snipers do it I'm going to get
on this one and we were so convinced the
house was going to blow up when we
initial plan was the land on top did we
were actually calling ourselves the
martyrs brigade like we're going to land
there it's going to blow up that's how
we're all going to die but but if we're
out we might get a shot and then none of
us ever went to the roof it didn't even
happen because the helicopter crashed
and they led us out here Andrews so when
you I want to I want to go back to the
to the photo where is this something you
go like okay we're going to need a photo
of this guy in training do you go wolf
we shoot him in the head his head could
burst apart because that's what happened
before is it just common sense well we
would generally take pictures of the
guys that we did kill because you wanted
you want to document everything that
happened here's what you know here's the
situation this do you want to be legal
with everything you know when you're a
good guys we're will arrest you but we
will kill you if you put up resistance
so we're used to taking pictures but
never to the point of the facial
recognition where we need the DNA we
need you know we I've been on missions
in Iraq going
when Abu Musab al-zarqawi was an ikemen
number one guy but we never he's not too
startled beheading started well yeah
they didn't start it but he made him oh
yeah he moved a popular yeah yeah they
started that stuff
yes century oh yeah well yeah I'm
grabbing laugh about beheadings well you
know it was more will FM is my idiotic
state no I know a terrible pain Engel
one though that he was the one that and
that actually that is terrorism that
that that scared people yeah I mean
that's that's evil it was it was I I was
I performed in Iraq in 2003 we heading I
know I did not know which I was a victim
or not when I went over to off to
perform for troops in Baghdad and you
know and Kirkuk in Chile oh and that was
right after that is when they started
and it frightened me so much I didn't
want to go back man he said helicopter
graduated they want to show you they
were so bad that was a alqaeda in Iraq
that became Isis they were so bad even
like leaders of Al Qaeda's like get your
little to rule
yeah weren't there a couple that they
said that you're you're doing this to a
Muslim this is terrible you because they
consider most victims of terrorists are
Muslims well you know and then they the
beheading the mass shootings that
they're doing I mean they're doing it
now it's still the same ideology that
started with without kind of with with
that version but yet I mean what they
wanted to do is they wanted to make
fewer people want to go over there which
I mean I can't blame that's that's scary
it scared me soak we flew around in
c-130s again it was only there for a
week and it was not like you know
anything compared to the guys who are on
the front lines with what they go
through at Blackhawk some from we didn't
do but that scared me so much that the
idea that I'd be in a Blackhawk that
would go down or whatever like I just
never went back so detected does work it
does it does it's case you're thinking
it's bad but there there's some bad
people over there do you have a favorite
movie based on the missions that you
were a part of um cuz it event I mean
you're part of the films you just said
yeah part of the mission of lone
survivors yeah this is a good movie I
liked it that's a funny one I'll get
I'll get asked how accurate is that
movie and I'll say add depends on who's
asking like where 70% if I'm talking to
some dudes but if it's happy hour and
some ladies I'll say you know it's a
hundred percent accurate I took all free
shots
I think I'm on Survivor did a good job
and I just watched out the other the
best more we've all time is Saving
Private Ryan I'm still mad that
Shakespeare in Love won the damn Best
Picture whole yeah but I think as far as
if you want to know what a mountain
gunfight in the mountains looks like
watch the lone survivor it's good and
we're and we were part of the rescue
that same team we were there for that
was my first deployment with that SEAL
team and we're up there for for that
just a and there's so much more going on
that like our part of that story we
weren't involved with that gun fight we
were trying to get him out right and it
was just never like the first time we
called it an a-10 on people and an a-10
is an anti-tank flying done and I
remember hearing it and I described that
how it goes over my head then impact and
we hear it fire and we came up with that
saying what doesn't kill you makes you
stronger except in a 10 and a 10 or
about that are you scared Wadi I'm sure
your hopefully you you are able to put
self-protect it uh are you scared
walking around because they you know in
daily life or for family or not scared
but aware you're aware we have stuff in
place I don't really get into the show
yeah there's there's you know guns dogs
whatever okay there's stuff in place
you're going to be okay I assume so yeah
was that a big disagree that a big party
occasion yeah I think about it a lot and
it's important means the complacency
kills its resting on your laurels and
just because something that hasn't
happened doesn't mean it won't do you
think that speaking up incoming because
I'm happy digs I wanted to know who you
are and I think a lot of people wanted
to know who you are you know is it one
of those things that's kind of a sign of
the times like we're much more geared
towards coming out and talking about
things now whereas we didn't 20 years
ago or 30 years ago like I did I mean I
think if people have always told their
stories historically there was a there's
a big gap about I can't talk about it
because nothing was going on like I mean
so you had Vietnam and there's a
thousands of books then you nothing and
then you have like Grenada books you
have Panama books
Desert Storm books like the books are
out there and I think it's good I think
if people go through that kind of thing
and it's a good story and it's good for
Americans to hear that I'm presenting
wrong with telling the historical
account like this book is the first one
that's about to involve some of these
raids that is approved by the Pentagon
which it was a submitted that they read
it they liked it to prove I don't use
anything wrong with them
with Americans knowing that there are
good people out to donut a question
about your desk this is the one one and
I love the book - thank you one thing is
they block out a word yes they did
however I got a call up a copy editor
here they block out TLC a SEAL team
blank no one knows what it is unless
we've been alive for the last five years
and they block out the number of the
SEAL team however earlier in the book
you say and now we named it that because
I guess they were spared it was SEAL
Teams wanted to and then yeah three I
guess he wanted the Russian formation
corn five the Pentagon was very gracious
I was I was very careful not to put
classified material in there and just
because it was I submitted it they had
to do something
they had yeah they gotta block some
stuff out they did a really good job I'm
very happy with them and so they blocked
blocked out a number so I don't know
what I can't figure it out because I
would they did mention as a SEAL team to
and I went see looking for and then I
would see looking blank that's true so
it's one of a few numbers you don't know
however the mistake they make though let
me call the copy either again is under
the double word event under they have
the blanked out thing and you can see
that it's three letters so I just you
can do the math on how many three
letters numbers there are so can I read
the whole actually did the audio book -
I read that out loud which is
interesting I got to do it on one last
proof read before it comes out there's
stuff in there that I thought they would
blank but they didn't so there's things
it like so I can't say this number but I
can say stealth helicopter well you also
didn't go into details about the
helicopter either no that's not
interesting people people don't a lot of
people don't want to know the mechanics
of this and they want to know what it
smelled like
like you like you asked earlier what it
what it what it is how did you how did
your friends feel looking at the at your
brother's eyes knowing this is probably
it but we're doing it and we're doing it
for the victims of 9/11 we're going for
the country it's just they want to know
that you know like a lot of people know
that you know the gamers and stuff to
know more about combat than I do ask me
what kind of stuff on the trigger I
don't know I mean the thing just it I
pulled it what the word out and you met
on the president the vice president of
course you must have met some amazing
people because of this yes I've been put
in spots where I do meet some pretty
cool people who did you meet that you
really wanted to meet or you get to
speak to the I've had access to
otherwise ah you know to be honest
Tony LaRussa he got manager from EA's
yeah uh yeah he's in Arizona now okay
did he manage das on my out of my mind
well because he actually got past my
security guy with a margarita innocent
why normally they can't do that logging
it shouldn't the bodyguards there to
guard this is a former SEAL team plane
guy as well
oh yeah and LaRussa showed up at the
margarita house going now that this
other SEAL team guy will you obviously
have people around you who really know
what they're doing I was he a guy you
knew before yeah I knew him in training
in 1996 so we kind of went around the
same time and then we ended up at UH at
SEAL team two together and then he went
over to the other team before I did then
I saw him there work with him there and
it's a it's interesting the way it like
like it mentioned about the name of the
operator it's about the life of the
operator all of them and it intertwines
there's a lot of people that I've met 96
and go through selection in 2004 and
then we're in Afghanistan looking for
lone survivor than he's a guy that takes
a shot at this samal it was so cool to
this they're so they're so humble that
it's almost like wow man you just made
worldwide headlines like yeah cool one
with the gym let's go for ground yeah
it's part of what you do is it yeah the
best part of that movie too was when the
snipers took the shot they just put the
bipod up and left that's exactly how it
went down
really there's this is usual very very
cool guys do you know what rereading all
the SEAL training stuff to which you can
never if you're a male you can never get
bored reading SEAL training stuff yeah
and it makes me realize how much I enjoy
being comfortable the stuff that you
guys have to deal with like that whether
it's carrying the boat on the head I
think the whole water this is and then
get it all things and it's just a common
question that I get is uh from like high
school-aged guys that want to be SEALs
they'll say what should I be doing to
prepare for this training and I said
well what are you doing and the common
answer is I'm taking cold showers to get
used to it oh my god that off right now
because just embrace the suck when it
gets there like what do you mean I said
well here's the deal if I told you in 30
days I'm going to kick you as hard as I
can in the nuts and you to get to get
ready for it yet your best friend kick
in the nuts every single day it's still
going to suck when I do it just to
create a point it happens right great
way to look at it 30 unnecessary nut
cake yeah there's no real in the shower
so yeah so I
thank you want to steal to take warm
showers everything will just fall into
place yes that simple do you have the
memories of being comfortable though
exactly because there's no way to
prepare I'm sure I saw a photo and I
might've even been above SEAL training
with these poor guys are lying in the
indus surf and they're laying there
holding up a log and of water is coming
over their face like you can't prepare
yourself the log yeah they they used to
have a log there one in particular that
was called old misery and it was like
three times as heavy as all the other
laws which were heavy and it just add
misery loves company and you get special
treatment you get to log now that log
was so evil like guys would try to swim
it out to sea on the weekends and get
rid of it would wash up me right back
where it's supposed to be what's the
closest to graduation you ever saw a guy
drop out you said one thing usually if
you make an iowa past wednesday usually
ona is a good indicator that you're
probably going to make it through hell
week and that's like the most famous
part there are harder test than hell
week to come but you've proven you can
get through hell week but there I mean
you got a figure we get into diving so
it's all the physiology the medicine the
dive tables all the calculations in the
mass and then you get into explosives
and electrical non electrical how to do
this and static and don't blow yourself
up so there's a lot of stuff but one of
my friends kind of lost his mind the
last part of SEAL training is then
people don't know about this it's on San
Clemente Island which is right off the
coast and the instructor because like I
mentioned earlier we're right by the
Hotel del Coronado for most of training
you go to the island the motto is no one
can hear you scream so it's 40 straight
days or whatever and I'm convinced some
of those guys brought some whiskey with
them because they wake up angry or than
other days you know and I saw a guy lose
his mind out there and they had they had
a Buddha but he ended up graduating with
two classes behind oh okay are they very
rare to quit what are they doing for 40
days it's technically land warfare so a
lot of shooting that's when you really
start getting into the weapons a lot of
the automatic weapons and the explosives
of patrolling small unit tactics just
the basic stuff but they're teaching you
now you're going to go to a SEAL team
you need to have a good base before
because after basic SEAL training then
ascending to 13 it was 13 weeks when I
got done I've sealed tactical training
now it's a more defined probably a
better course advanced tactics and then
so it takes about two years if you make
it through everything on the first try
to become soo can you describe the
hiding because I get a bit
claustrophobic yeah that's that's the
tunnel
oh yeah they they like to do the Beehive
ink it's not a test it's just more of an
experience when you have about 180 200
guys in the class and they they tell you
to get as close as you can together in
the deep end of the pool right so if you
can imagine a big just a big group of
dudes and people have a tendency to
freak out when they involve water
drowning is a really horrible feeling so
people will like grab each other's heads
and push each other down to try to stay
up so you got a bunch of guys doing this
and the only thing you got to do is go
to the bottom take a wrap off relax and
then swim to the edge and come up on
these and then work your way back inside
keep doing that but you know kind of
panic if your panic is not going to help
it's okay to be afraid
fear is good like fear makes you think
more clearly you know like you can hear
like imagine when you're at home
watching the scary movie and you hear
everything right
like I'm 41 years old I was a Navy SEAL
I'll be watching the movie by myself the
ice machine goes off and like Satan
fears fine but panic is very final out
to mean that that thing of like when
you're watching a scary movie and all of
a sudden you hear every creep down
floorboard and every but you have to be
and I guess as part of training you have
to be aware enough to okay stop for a
second and use all this and then make a
decision as opposed to just going on and
so that's the whole it doesn't mean
you're not afraid it's what you do about
it yeah you do it anyway you can deal
with fair it's okay to be afraid but
they were guys too and to me the most
amazing thing I read in your book was
that on the way to bin Laden's house
there were guys in that helicopter that
fell asleep yes I can't sleep on a king
bed hotel and this guy they were it was
incredible it was put the put the iPod
in turn it up and fall asleep especially
especially with what you told us before
which was people go in that's not only
not knowing if they'll make it but
assuming coming we're not going to make
it no it's like well if I'm going to I'm
going to die doing this I might as well
be 12 hours yeah right I mean how
amazing is I could get blown up any
second any second but I'm going to take
five and right sweep it all but it goes
back it goes back to get your mind up
and and it goes back to training for
being a seal it's like I'm not going to
do something now that's going to make me
uncomfortable
I can't I know everything that I'm going
to know going into this so I might as
well be as comfortable as possible in
these last few moments some guys biggest
concern was why don't want to have to
pee when I get there so how do I do it
on someone's vanities like diaper things
you don't pull out a little diaper looks
like a dog bone you can pee in that I
didn't even use mine I used a water
bottle and I was so pumped to be in
binlong house I forgot I had a bottle of
urine in my pocket you carried you
you're in an accident didn't mean
whatever you are not that sort outside
the helicopter it's the souvenir now
it's an advantage is this is long as
well you gave I thought you gave part of
your your magazine to the woman who I
did you think that was a really nice a
magazine out of the gun and gave it to
to her shoot I mean that was her thing
see she sacrificed her whole life to
find him she gets she didn't get married
she didn't have a personal life she's I
will find him and she was 100% right and
they really changed the day of the raid
because of the White House
Correspondents Dinner yeah we had two
days based on we wanted 0% illumination
from the moon so we had either Saturday
or Sunday that we can do it and Saturday
we someone I didn't but someone called
the White House and said hey were
probably the Admiral McRaven or somebody
and said hey we're going to move it
because the weather was bad so we're
shifting to tomorrow and I guess they
were like it's 2011 we know exactly what
the weather's doing it's night we just
said because the Correspondents Dinner
that all the cabinet gets up in the
middle of it all the presses there
what's going on people start calling so
and even uh President Obama was getting
roasted at that dinner I got house on
bin Laden actually hosts a show on
c-span every day at this time and he
just poker face probably the best line
ever done in a correspondence it was
Seth Meyers said that I would add c-span
was Obama bin Laden it was hosted a show
and he's never saw one day everyone
watches c-span could they watch now was
there video could they actually see live
action you know they could see from
above they had some assets above us to
watch but they weren't in the house they
couldn't see in the house and and we
don't want them to see what's going on
and you know you're here well everyone
Wargo GoPros nobody there was no cameras
inside we had the disposable camera take
the picture that's it were you able to
keep a copy of the photo no you or not
no so me begging you after this
interview that I
it's I don't have it I I don't know how
I feel about that I mean it's all [ __ ]
for us we demonstrated on the fan you
know it's one of those things where you
saw it that you don't need to have the
picture no I mean I can close my eyes
and see see what happened I I can I can
I can see the stairs I can see the
curtain I could turn the corner see the
white I can see the little kid as
two-year-old boy and I remember thinking
this kid has nothing to do with this
poor guy and like I watch guys on that
mission putting kids at different spots
because even though we're probably going
to blow up I don't need that little girl
being more afraid than she needs to be
soft find a place to put her and the
books are sorry I'm sorry the operator
firing the shots that killed Osama bin
Laden I'm guessing it's out today it's
out today it's out now are you doing any
book signings or no I did an online
signing yesterday and again it's the
security of yours I mean I would like to
I probably will I'm not sure where yet
but yeah we put out a couple sign copies
yesterday and that's available right now
and it's a great read I mean I really I
mean I knew a lot about this because
I've read about it I've seen the movie
but there's a lot of stuff in here about
the training and about the the rate is
so much detail in here I was really
happy I didn't just take for granted I
knew what I was talking about I want to
breathing it was really great and the
signed copies are available at the
operator book.com so if you want a
signed copy of the book you can buy it
right now have the operator book calm
I'll be silent for a while
what are you doing now with your selling
like you obviously do in the book yes
but now that you're out how do you top
that in vain' life like what would be my
greatest satisfaction now is helping
veterans transition to the private
sector because you'll notice in the book
too that I didn't do 20 years I did
almost 17 and I got out and the scariest
part is like I don't fit now that it
would rather go to combat and try to
fill out a resume because the combat
makes sense to them I don't know what do
I have what are my skills but these guys
have this the stress management the team
awareness the big one now is loyalty
that employer say so I started a
foundation to help them call your
grateful nation and I helped special
operators so it's Rangers Green Berets
SEALs Air Force we find a mentor for
them in a business and a place they want
to live and work and they mentor them
for six to nine months give them a job
in there we got everything from we got
guys working to Fox Sports to a NASCAR
stuff all kinds of good things and they
love them so you're grateful nation it
helps them transition that's and the
best email I get every week is
say we play sergeant so-and-so with
Goldman Sachs right and they go there
and they do like they always add a
crushing and and and you know your your
life and the things you've seen and the
things you've been a part of what is
that what is the biggest thing that
people don't understand about it that
that they get wrong whether it's in the
news or publicly when they criticize
what's the thing you're like you just
don't know what you're talking about I'm
just at the negativity with what our men
and women do over there so you get it's
like anything you had a couple bad eggs
and it just makes everyone look bad like
these these people that I've seen the 19
year old marine the 25 year old Ranger
these are the good guys they're really
good people they really care about
people and they're trying to do the
right thing and when they when a lot of
people just to get headlines wanted want
to stress war crimes and go to the evil
one it's like now they're doing a good
thing and they're away from their family
and they matter and you also said in GI
Jane you guys did not eat out of a
garbage can
I thought you know her name was O'Neill
in that movie what yeah that's my name
is she spelled it with one L but that's
not the worst I've ever seen it now we
don't actually force-feed you then
you're burning so many calories a date
or a SEAL training they make you eat
it's a fine line though because you
don't want to scarf down five
cheeseburgers and then do it six mile
run it's that's not a good idea
what are those between regular SEAL
training and then the idea of the team
whatever you know team we don't know
ambiguous that what's the difference in
the training between haha the seal and
exactly when you're going for the the
Tier one team it's everyone there is an
experience usually what combat
experience a seasoned Navy SEAL so
they're going to you know they're going
to die before they can't do something so
you're not going to make them quit so we
come up with drills to get in their mind
stress management drills how do you how
do you handle stress little things it's
a very very advanced fast-moving tactics
where you're going to get hammered for
not permit not making a mistake but
we're telling you you did to see how you
can you can you get over it so it's a
50% when I left 50% of seals that tried
out didn't make it that's Samsung these
are very very very serious people after
going through that kind of training do
you find that when you get back into
regular life your tolerance for people's
excuse me diminish is I don't I don't
like traffic the traffic still gets to
me but as far as like the other stuff
yes the what the best story I have about
that getting out of life like this
I don't have a desire to scuba dive or
skydive or even shoot guns anymore and I
had a psychiatrist in the Navy say well
you need a hobby to relieve stress so
she had me take up golf which actually
is more stressful than combat and I also
mentioned to the de fog if they sent me
after Ben LAN with a 5-iron he might
still be alive
it's one of those things where you still
have to have that instinct even though
you seem like a humble guy where
somebody will tell you you can't do
something or like nada we don't have
room for you today sir you have to just
want to say yeah it's frustrating
getting the extra security check at the
airport and then the selfie with the TSA
guy that's frustrating
they asked like who I was and I'm not a
threat to I'm not going to blow the
plane up but let's go ahead and Pat me
down a little bit and grab a selfie I
think that you know because they want to
selfie it could be they need to slow you
down so they can get the opportunity to
be like oh and one more thing I like to
give them the benefit of the doubt
though because I deal with passengers
all day so once they recognize you that
fella go well how else am I going to
talk to him I would say just touch him
into your arms [ __ ] want to try it for
so gain a quick cup yeah that's a little
creepy I don't know [ __ ] yeah I guess so
yeah he shopped a lot guess I did to him
well I get I appreciate you coming buddy
our book is called the operator again we
keep saying it but it's excellent I'm
not saying that to be polite because
you're sitting here I read a lot of it I
read the most of the beginning I were
also yet phenomenal and there's a lot of
information here it's well written it's
an easy read it's really great were you
surprised when a conspiracy theorist or
as a pop-up that because there's no
photo evidence this didn't have no
receptors are for the people they like I
mentioned earlier usually the simplest
answer is what happened but people make
it like the big secret societies of this
and that and that we didn't land on the
moon the earth is flat no it's like
you're not in the Illuminati is that
we're doing or not is what I was looking
for do it not that you know thank you
yeah maybe that's the word that was it
out of the one nail this is me I sealed
Illuminati yeah before we let you go
just a couple people want to say hello
or thank you and there's a guy here who
was a Navy veteran
- tain
sorry hello everybody all right I got
hello
okay let's meet you there yes we're good
okay the special was awesome and Sam
congratulations on the little one a
senior Keith what's up buddy how's it
going my friend I'm gonna l-3 from
Desert Storm and I just want to say from
what may be man to the next thank you
buddy and I had the privilege to hang
out with some guys that were in buds 151
back in oh wow yeah you [ __ ]
are crazy thank you buddy
thank you for your service that's
awesome thanks for the call and one more
guys a question for you i ray ray hello
ray ray in West Point hi I'm Robert big
head and I'm just watching thank you
thank you for saying I didn't and I just
have to two questions really really
quick um I'm just uh I'm the simple army
brat arm when you when you flew in with
a Blackhawks or they like super quiet or
this kind of loud uh you know anything
with the helicopter is going to be loud
I was impressed with with how they were
pretty quiet and it was just more the
radar stuff that they were pretty good
at but a lot of a lot of helicopters
have that and it pretty much looked like
a like a Blackhawk it was a little more
a little more room back okay second
question which one which one's better
five five six or or or a 300 blackout
what depends on what you're doing five
five six with a hollow-point worked
pretty well for me most of my shots were
really really close I think it's 300 for
anything over 500 meters all right Roger
that
cool thanks we I didn't know what you
mentioned piece of challah for you my
god well thank you very much Rob really
fascinating guy I'm so happy we got a
chance I really ended